-Our first guest tonight
is an Academy, Emmy, Grammy,
and Tony Award-winning musician.
His new album "Bigger Love
is on sale now,
and he's currently serving
as a coach on this season
of "The Voice," which airs
Mondays and Tuesdays
right here on NBC.
Please welcome back to the sho
John Legend.
How are you, John?
-Hey, Seth. Good to see you.
-Good to see you as well.
Obviously, a lot of people wer
celebrating this weekend.
You guys made it a family affair
in Los Angeles.
-Yes, we did.
We were feeling the energy
around us
and seeing on social media
so many people out
honking their horns
and celebrating,
and we were like,
"Let's get out of the house.
Let's go and interact
with the people."
So we went out
to West Hollywood,
Santa Monica Boulevard,
and there was an impromptu
dance party happening,
and we just drove through
for a little bit
and celebrated with the crowd.
-We actually have
a short video here.
Here you are with the family
-Hey!
[ Crowd cheering ]
-Whoo!
-It should be noted, to a lo
of voters in America,
that's what West Hollywood
always looks like.
[ Light laughter ]
-Yes. That's a fair --
that's a fair approximation.
[ Laughs ]
But it was really nice to
celebrate with everybody.
-That's great. I want to ask
as well, about "The Voice.
Very exciting to have anothe
season going.
How's it been for you so far
-It's been so good.
You know, this is our
first season
in the COVID environment
where we were able to go bac
to the studio
and with all of these new
protocols, tape the show,
but the talent hasn't
changed a bit.
In fact, I've said that
this year's blind audition
were the best group of singers
that we've had
since I've been on the show,
which this is my fourth season
So, I'm really impressed
with the artists
that we're able to work with
and I think we're putting on
a really great show
for the country.
-It is so exciting
to watch any kind of
live performance these days,
and the show's done
such a good job
of grabbing that.
Of course, there are reall
strong COVID protocols in place.
We talked to Gwen about
how she used a T-shirt canno
to shoot T-shirts to her team.
You took a different approach.
You can't quite tell what
we're talking about
with this picture there,
but this close-up
really brings home
how creepy that is.
Was that your idea?
-I took a substantially
inferior approach to --
[ Laughter ]
"The Voice" producer suggested
I use a rubber hand
to reach out and shake
everyone's hand,
and you can see how creepy
it looks.
And, I make fun of myself and my
glove for the entire season,
and deservedly so.
[ Laughs ]
-You -- I know
you have new music.
You have a new album.
-Yes.
-Obviously, you're not alone
in being a performer
who hasn't been able to get ou
and do live shows.
Are you hopeful you'll be able
to do that soon?
And how badly
have you missed it?
-Well, with the good news
about the vaccine today,
I'm hopeful that the world
can get back to normal
by the middle of next year
We have a tour scheduled
for August.
We postponed it from this year's
August to next year's August
So, we'll see
if it's able to happen,
but I think the news
about the vaccine
makes that a little more
possible.
-You're doing a song for u
tonight later in the show
called "Wild."
What was the inspiration
behind that song?
-Well, it's a song about being
in love, and being passionate.
And the video, of course,
featured my wife and our family,
and it's a really powerful song.
Also features the great
Gary Clark Jr. on guitar.
He's not on our performanc
tonight,
but he's on the album version.
And I -- it's really one of my
favorite songs on the album,
one of Chrissy's favorites
and hopefully everyone
loves it tonight.
-I want to end that you were
in Philly with your family
again supporting -- this was
the night before the election,
so before he was
president-elect.
-Yes.
-Was that a special night?
Did you enjoy being there
supporting?
-It was so special.
We wanted to be there to help.
We knew that Pennsylvania
was going to be close,
and we knew that if
we could drive up turnout
in Philadelphia
and the surrounding areas,
that Joe Biden would have
a chance to win.
And Philly came through,
Pennsylvania came through,
other states around the countr
came through.
And we're very, very excited
that Joe Biden
is the president-elect
of the country.
We need someone with his
leadership skills, his empathy
his intelligence, his team
We think it's going to be much
better for the country.
-Well, I'm neither here
nor there on it,
because I'm not political.
[ Laughter ]
-Clearly.
Absolutely neutral!
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
And thank you, as well,
for doing the song for us.
We can't wait to see it.
It's always a pleasure
to see you.
Love to your family.
-Thank you, Seth.
Great to see you too.
-"Bigger Love" is out now,
and "The Voice" airs
Mondays and Tuesdays
right here on NBC.